many scientists work on theoretical
Concepts but James clerk Maxwell's work
was unique because it led to the
development of practical inventions like
the TV he changed the world forever
those aren't my words but the words of
Albert Einstein Einstein was referring
to Maxwell's most famous discovery that
magnetism and electricity were linked
without this understanding many of the
Technologies we rely on would not exist
before we delve into his groundbreaking
discovery Maxwell's scientific career
had begun long before at the age of 14
when he published his first academic
paper it described an unusual way of
drawing geometric curves using twine a
prominent professor at Edinburgh
University described it as ingenious the
paper was important not for its content
but for the effect it had on Maxwell it
put him on a path to a career in
mathematics
Maxwell was born in Edinburgh on June 13
1831 one and grew up in the country on a
big estate his parents built in
Southwest Scotland
he had an older sister who died in
infancy his mother was nearly 40 when he
was born as a little boy he was
fascinated by how things worked when he
was two he pulled a rope in one room and
was amazed that a bell rang in another
like magic or rather like science then
he discovered the wires hidden in the
walls his mum described him as
inquisitive writing show me how it does
is never out of his mouth as a boy he
could recite long passages of John
Milton's poems he loved poetry and wrote
his own later in life his memory was so
good that he could recite all 176 verses
of Psalm 119. he was a devout Christian
a man of God and also a man of science
he wrote science is but an image of the
truth and should speak only so far as it
is spoken to in other words it cannot
provide all pieces of the puzzle his
mother was responsible for his Early
Education but when he was eight she died
of abdominal cancer the same disease
that would take his own life
a private tutor didn't work out either
he reportedly beat Maxwell and chided
him for being slow then when Maxwell was
10 he was sent to the prestigious
Edinburgh Academy but he had a hard time
fitting in he was teased for his
homemade shoes strange country dress in
his strong Galloway accent his peers
called him dafty which is Scottish slang
for silly or foolish
he was anything but however his peers
couldn't understand his Brilliance
Maxwell would draw diagrams they didn't
understand and make mechanical models
that didn't make sense to them later at
the University of Edinburgh he still
struggled to fit in it wasn't until he
arrived at the University of Cambridge
that his talents began to be recognized
his math tutor at Cambridge William
Hopkins is reported to have said that
Maxwell was the most extraordinary man
he had ever met when Maxwell later
applied for a teaching position at
Marshall College in Aberdeen Scotland to
be closer to his father whose Health was
deteriorating Hopkins wrote this glowing
reference letter his mind is devoted to
the prosecution of scientific studies
and it is impossible that he should not
become if his life is spared one of the
most distinguished men of Science in
this or any other country
Maxwell became the chair of natural
philosophy at Marshall College what they
used to call physics he headed the
entire department at the age of 25. but
his dad would never see him in this role
he passed away before he took up the
position which was a terrible loss as
they were very close Maxwell married the
daughter of the head of Marshall College
who was seven years his senior their
marriage was childless but very fruitful
Catherine helped him with experiments
including his famous ones on color he
realized that the human eye can only see
red blue and green light any other
colors we see are a mixture of these
Maxwell was the first to show that any
color can be produced by combining three
primary colors in appropriate
proportions he calculated the exact
amount of red blue and green needed to
make any other color and displayed it on
a colored triangle this led to a method
for creating color photographs he
proposed that a color image could be
created by taking three separate
photographs each with a different color
filter red green and blue by
superimposing the images together the
full color image could be reconstructed
his colleague Thomas Sutton applied this
method to create the world's first color
photograph of a Tartan ribbon in 1861.
while at Marshall College he also spent
two years solving a problem that had
stumped scientists for 200 years ever
since Galileo first observed Saturn's
rings what were Saturn's rings made of
nobody had any idea scientists thought
they might have been solid but if they
were they should have been crashing into
each other or crashing into the planet
Maxwell used math to show that the only
way the Rings could remain relatively
stable is if they consisted of many
small particles each independently
orbiting Saturn when the Voyager probes
flew by Saturn more than a hundred years
later in the 1980s and sent back images
they proved he was right despite
Maxwell's Stellar scientific reputation
he lost his job when Marshall College
merged with a neighboring King's College
to form the University of Aberdeen and
his position became redundant he applied
for a chair at the University of
Edinburgh but lost out to his childhood
friend physicist Peter Tate fortunately
his resume impressed King's College
London which appointed him chair of
natural philosophy in 1860. before
taking up his new position he suffered
from an attack of smallpox which nearly
killed him he credited his wife with
saving his life a few years later it
would be Maxwell who nursed his wife
back to health when she fell very ill
Maxwell's biographer and friend
described their marriage as one of
unexampled devotion
his years in London were his most
productive that's actually an
understatement many scientists including
Einstein and Richard feinman regard
Maxwell's work during this period as the
most important discovery of the 20th
century
Maxwell discovered that magnets
attracting or repelling each other or
electricity making a light bulb turned
on are connected he built on the work of
self-educated physicist Michael Faraday
who had shown that a moving magnet could
make electricity flow through a coil of
wire this mysterious interaction between
magnetism and electricity was called
electromagnetism Maxwell worked out that
varying electric and magnetic forces
could create waves of energy that travel
through space without any wires like
ripples across the surface of the water
he discovered that electromagnetic waves
traveled at the speed of light just says
there's a range of different colors of
light he theorized that light was just
one type of a whole range of
electromagnetic waves in that there are
other types that the human eye can't see
radio waves microwaves x-rays this paved
the way for the radio microwaves to heat
food and x-ray machines pretty much any
modern electrical or electronic
technology which relies on the
transmission of electromagnetic waves
through the air to send and receive
signals in 1865 Maxwell described all
that was known about the relationship
between electricity and magnetism and a
set of equations that now bear his name
Maxwell's equations also gave Einstein
the tools to develop his most famous
Theory Einstein showed that the speed of
light never changes no matter the
reference frame which Maxwell's
equations helped establish for example
if I threw this ball toward you at 20
miles an hour if you were running toward
me the ball would appear to approach you
more quickly and if you were to run away
from me then the ball would appear to
approach you less quickly but that's not
the case with light if I were to fire a
laser beam at you then regardless of
whether you're running toward me away
from me or if you're standing still the
light would appear to approach you at
the same speed this revolutionized our
understanding of the universe it's no
wonder when someone pointed out Einstein
stood on the shoulders of the work of
Newton he reportedly corrected them by
saying no I don't I stand on the
shoulders of Maxwell
he even had a portrait of Maxwell
hanging in his office
in 1871 Maxwell became the first
Cavendish professor of physics one of
the most senior faculty positions in
physics at Cambridge University he was
in charge of developing the Cavendish
laboratory which has since produced more
than 30 Nobel laureates
despite his many scientific
contributions Maxwell was relatively
unknown outside of Academia his work was
largely foundational he helped plant the
seed for future discoveries
he also died when he was relatively
Young
in April 1879 he began having difficulty
swallowing a symptom of abdominal cancer
which took his mother's life and would
take his at the same age
toward the end of his life Maxwell told
a Cambridge colleague I have been
thinking how very gently I've always
been dealt with I've never had a violent
shove all my life the only desire which
I can have is like David in reference to
King David from the Bible to serve my
own Generation by the will of God and
then fall asleep
Maxwell died on November 5 1879 at the
age of 48.
he was buried in a churchyard not far
from where he grew up alongside his wife
and parents
his headstone is a simple one not what
you might expect for a man of his
stature despite his immense
contributions to science he received few
public honors during his lifetime but
over time he has been increasingly
recognized and celebrated there's a
popular saying that references his
brilliance and God said Maxwell's
equations and there was light
Maxwell used math to explain the
fundamental principles of electricity
and magnetism that paved the way for
countless Innovations if you're
interested in exploring the power of
math I highly recommend brilliant.org a
website and app where you can learn math
in a fun and engaging way what I really
like about brilliant is that it's super
interactive like this lesson on
exploring the concept of fractions and
then you can progress through Concepts
that are more challenging there's
something for everyone whether you're a
beginner or you'd like to keep your
skills sharp in Step brilliant offers
thousands of courses everything from
computer science to data science to AI
if you're ever stuck you can click the
explanation to see where you went wrong
I enjoy using brilliant to go through
their logic puzzles to boost my
analytical thinking skills you can try
out brilliant for free for 30 days by
visiting my custom link in the
description
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people who sign up with my link will
get 20 person off Brilliance annual
premium subscription